the kardashians fans still can't get
over it but two people who know them
better than anyone
think it's the right move caitlyn jenner
in paris hill
what do you think of the fact that
keeping up with the kardashians they
just announced is going to end
i think just like with the simple life i
just was over it
who was the first caller text about it
ending the first one was kim
any tears over it yeah you know it's
kind of sad to see it end
but we'll all be okay
they have huge business empires i'm sure
that's
what they want to spend their time doing
that and being with their families
why now i think it was just phenomenal
success
let's move on and do the other things
we're doing after 20 seasons
i think they're just ready to live their
life and not have to be on camera every
second
paris knows all about living her life on
camera she was the original famous for
being famous reality tv star
who survived a sex tape scandal in the
headlines back in two thousand three
now the thirty-nine-year-old heiress
turned dj is sharing what fans didn't
know
about her life from what she calls
abusive exes
to being kidnapped hilton covers it all
in her new documentary this is paris
streaming monday on her youtube channel
something happened to my childhood that
i've never talked about with anyone
i still have nightmares about it that
tape was one of the most painful
experiences i've ever been through in my
life
and i would never have put myself in
that position or met a man like that
if i had not went through what i went
through
now paris is focused on being an
activist growing her empire
and her future with businessman carter
rheem i'm always going to be a boss babe
but i'm also going to be a grown-up and
i'll be a mom
and wife 2021 definitely caitlyn jenner
is also looking forward to the future
and you can still keep up with caitlyn
on her youtube channel
actually i got some really fun stuff
with kylie coming up i do
her makeup here i am i'm doing her
makeup on a billion dollar face you know
it's a little scary by the way the last
time i talked to you i asked if you
would ever
join as a possible next venture real
housewives of beverly hills
now that chris is free people are saying
maybe chris should join it what do you
think
i think chris could get in with those
girls and mix it up and have
no problem whatsoever much better than i
can
i'm not into all the drama but i want
you both on there
now we're talking drama again yes
you